ahora que vimos la rotación al
multiplicar jota por jota una y otra vez
lo que nos da la rotación ahora vamos a
hacerlo para la idea general de
cualquier número complejo si tengo un
número complejo que llamo z que está
compuesto de dos partes una parte real
que llamamos a y otra parte imaginaria
que llamamos b y ahora lo que quiero
hacer es ver qué pasa si multiplico zeta
por j una vez jota por zeta es igual a
jota por a más jota por b lo
multiplicamos y nos queda jota por a más
jota por jota por ver ahora vamos a
intercambiar de lugar
lleve aquí ponemos jota por ar y aquí
que tenemos jota por jota es igual a
menos 1 así que tenemos menos b más j
por a ahora tenemos las expresiones para
zeta y jota por zeta vamos a graficar
esto en un plano complejo para ver cómo
lucen este es el eje real este es el eje
imaginario y primero vamos a graficar z
digamos que z tiene un
pero real bastante grande aquí está y
digamos que ve tiene un valor menor
vamos a ponerlo aquí vamos a ponerlo
aquí en nuestro eje imaginario así que
la ubicación de z en este plano complejo
es está aquí indicamos bien las
coordenadas y aquí está se está en el
plano complejo ahora graphic hemos jota
por zeta
ahora jota por zeta tiene un componente
real de menos b que estará más o menos
por aquí
aquí tenemos menos b y tiene un
componente imaginario de a positivo que
está hasta por acá
esta es la ubicación de j por zeta
dibujamos la hipotenusa de esto y este
es el vector que representa a este
número complejo
aquí tenemos bastantes triángulos lo que
quiero demostrar es que este ángulo de
aquí es de 90 grados
vamos a hacerlo digamos que el ángulo de
aquí es teta este triángulo de aquí
abajo imaginen que vamos a rotarlo hasta
que el lado
de este triángulo quede sobre el eje
imaginario así que este triángulo rota
hasta quedar en este y ya que movimos
este triángulo sabemos que este ángulo
de aquí también va a ser theta es el
mismo triángulo solo que lo rotamos
hacia la izquierda y este ángulo de aquí
a que va a ser igual pues va a ser igual
a 90 grados menos theta así que si
combino este ángulo de teta con este
ángulo de aquí nos va a quedar theta más
90 grados menos theta y nos quedan 90
grados acabamos de demostrar que este
ángulo de aquí es un ángulo recto mide
90 grados lo que demuestra que cualquier
número complejo z si lo multiplicó por
jota nos va a dar una rotación positiva
de 90 grados vamos a hacer de nuevo esta
rotación pero en lugar de usar el
sistema de coordenadas rectangulares
usemos la representación exponencial en
la notación exponencial en general
decimos qué
z es igual a cierto radio por el ala j
teta donde este es el ángulo teta y r es
la longitud de esta hipotenusa para
llegar a z en esta anotación a que es
igual a j por z va a ser igual a jota
por r por a la jota teta y ahora vamos a
usar un truco voy a representar jota en
notación exponencial aquí en la gráfica
estoy dibujando j el rector jota está
aquí tiene una magnitud de 1 y apunta
hacia arriba sobre el eje imaginario así
que puedo representar jota como esto
jota es igual
a la jota por 90 grados
esto es equivalente a esta jota de aquí
que multiplica a ere por e
a la jota teta y el último paso es
combinar estos exponenciales nos queda
jota por zeta igual a r por e a la jota
por teta más 90 grados así que de
notación exponencial
tenemos este vector de aquí con una
rotación adicional de 90 grados y vamos
a llegar a la misma distancia que
llegamos originalmente r
así que acabamos demostrar que podemos
rotar cualquier número complejo 90
grados si lo multiplicamos por j vamos a
aplicar esta transformación al trabajar
con las relaciones de corriente y
voltaje en inductores y capacitores y
eso lo veremos en futuros vídeos